je commence avec vous christian cambon
c'est l'otan qui est assez alarmiste
l'otan s'attend à une attaque de grande
envergure des troupes russes en ukraine
évidemment nous on se demandait ce qu'on
peut encore éviter la guerre quand on
quand on lit une phrase pareille
sincèrement je crois que cette fois ci
ça va être très difficile ça va être
très difficile parce qu'il ya une autre
nouvelle qui vient de tomber cet après
midi
le président poutine a annoncé que dans
son esprit
l'occupation
de donetsk est lougansk c'était les
régions administratives c'est à dire ces
quatre fois l'équivalent de ce qu'ils
étaient occupés
dans les jours précédents donc d'ores et
déjà et de ses archives et pardon nous
interrompt pourra regarder les cartes y
avait
à bien qu il y avait effectivement de
territoire qui est qui qui était
séparatistes on va dire hélas hélas
poutine va encore plus loin c'est ça
c'est environ trois fois la superficie
des républiques initial tel qu'on l'ait
concevait ya encore trois jours quoi ré
et donc ça veut dire que la politique de
proxy d'occupation de proximité va
continuer et le piège que poutine temps
aux ukrainiens et à l'occident du maire
général
si maintenant vous faites un pas s'il ya
le moindre blessé j'avance et je fais
rentrer les troupes et voilà donc on va
je ne vois pas franchement d'espoir à
l'heure où nous parlons sylvain quand
vous êtes dans le même le même état
d'esprit c'est à dire que la machine
malheureusement est enclenché duriez ça
je sais pas si la machine est enclenchée
mais en tout cas c'est sûr que le fait
que les dirigeants autoproclamés les
république
elle-même autoproclamée indépendante
reconnue donc depuis hier par l'état
russe le fait que viennent d'annoncer
que leur territoire triplet de
superficie
c'est très inquiétant parce que jusqu'à
présent il ya effectivement une ligne il
y avait quelque chose qui ressemble à
une ligne de front
qui délimitait on va dire les régions
qui s'était séparée du reste de
l'ukraine et la poutine vient
d'expliquer qu' il faut faire avancer
cette ligne de front et qui est devenu
pour 10 d'une frontière on prendre sur
cette ligne de front de l'autre côté il
ya des troupes l'ukrainienne aujourd'hui
donc quand ils disent on trie plus le
territoire est ce que sur cette partie
supplémentaire il ya des troupes
l'ukrainienne aujourd'hui bah disons que
on va le dire comme ça on va dire que
cette cette partie cette bande qui est à
l'est de l'ukraine et qui est donc
frontalière de la russie qui fait à peu
près 400 km de large d'accord
et bien était dé facto soustraite à la
souveraineté de l'état ukrainien bon
aujourd'hui ce que dit poutine et les
deux gouvernements fantoches de ces deux
républiques autoproclamées c'est que il
faut passer des choses très
schématiquement d'une bande de 400 km de
profondeur à une bande de quatre à trois
à douze mille deux cents kilomètres de
profondeur et donc ça veut dire mordre
encore davantage sur ceux qui
aujourd'hui relève la souveraineté de
l'état ukrainien alors encore une fois
comme l'a dit monsieur le sénateur
c'est comme ailleurs c'est une annonce
d'accord donc on a on s'attend
effectivement à ce que l'idée en toute
logique est-ce qu'il puisse y avoir des
mouvements de troupes ça veut pas dire
que ça arrivera bien que ça veut dire
aussi qu poutine continue sa stratégie
de la tension with all là aussi ça peut
être aussi un début de négociation d'une
certaine façon je dois négocier sur une
croix parce que choisir
dit jeudi en une façon de pousser son
avantage il n'entend qu'un langage la
diva poutine c'est la force et le
rapport de force et il se trouve qu'il
n'ya que lui qui usent de la force
puisque en face la seule arme que
développe pour l'instant les les le bloc
occidental s'était d'abord l'outil de
négociation et de la discussion émincez
les sanctions économiques mais d'un
point de vue militaire tant que personne
ne résiste et c'est là où va se poser la
question avec toutes les rues de cannes
est la question de poutine sait jusqu'où
ne pas aller trop loin mais pour
l'instant il peut y aller parce que
personne si oui vous avez raison d'y
arriver mais il est vrai que si
imaginons ce qui pour l'instant n'est
pas le cas que les armées russes
franchissent ce qui est aujourd'hui la
ligne de front dé facto ça veut dire qu
effectivement à ce moment là tout le
monde pourra parler on va dire d'une
invasion de l'ukraine au sens de
l'ukraine qui jusqu'àlors était
disons indépendante sous souveraineté du
gouvernement ukrainien donc là il ya un
casus belli au carré et du coup ça veut
dire que le gouvernement ukrainien
serait très probablement amenés à
résister et à considérer qu'il ya une
déclaration de guerre qui vient de lui
être qui lui aurait été faite donc ce
n'est pas encore sûr qu'au bout d'une
impasse parce que le coût évidemment de
déclencher une guerre avec le
gouvernement ukrainien disons dans ces
conditions serait très coûteux ouais
vladimir kozhin qui a de nouveau pris la
parole en fin d'après midi avec un
message justement aux hauts dirigeants
ukrainiens on écoute le président russe
la meilleure solution à ce problème
serait pour que nos collègues des pays
occidentaux ne perdent pas ce qu'on
appelle la face que les autorités
actuelles de kiev refuse-t-elle même
d'adhérer à l'otan et choisissent la
neutralité et si encore on comment vous
réagissez en entendant ça on parle
depuis plusieurs jours d'une
finlandisation possible de de l'ukraine
c'est ce que l'un des murs poutine a en
tête ou alors c'est finalement il prêche
le faux pour pour faire avancer pour
pour une espèce de francs de fumée pour
pour continuer d'avancer ses pions
militairement en attendant ce que
poutine a en tête c'est effectivement de
mettre la main du meilleur ou d'une
autre sur l'ensemble de sur l'ensemble
de l'ukraine il faut quand même pas
l'ensemble de l'ukraine oui je pense
alors ça prendra le temps que ça que ça
veut enfin reprenant le discours d'hier
ce n'est pas un état ce sont des
fantoches faut faut relire ce qu'il a
dit est dit c'est un plan que auquel
j'ai réfléchi depuis longtemps ces
décisions mûrissait depuis longtemps
donc on va avoir des périodes de tension
dps de cadres mais au fur et à mesure on
assiste déjà depuis hier on est on a
déjà multiplié par trois la zone
théorique d'occupation des de l'armée
russe donc morceau par morceau ça
commence ça va commencer à bien faire or
c'est quand même pas à
poutine de dicter ce que doit faire le
gouvernement ukrainien alors que c'est
lui qui la grèce coiffage veut dire il
ya des principes de souveraineté alors
dans ce cas là tout est ouvert et puis
de vernon ve avenue j
voilà c'est terminé c'est qui s'appuie
sur un précédent 14ème la crimée et
comme les oxydes houle était soi-disant
au ban des nations où il ya eu tout un
attirail de sanctions économiques et/ou
et/ou et bien vous avez vu la dernière
poutre poutine disparaître de la scène
internationale non elle n'y a pas
empêchés d'organiser la coupe du monde
quel point le temps ça peut empêcher de
faire de faire beaucoup de choses c'est
assez intéressant sur ce thème là on
écoute françois hollande tient je vous
propose de voir la réaction de l'ancien
président français qui dit que vladimir
poutine ne comprend que la force un peu
vous évoquez tout à l'heure françois
hollande jusqu'en 2014 quand il y a eu
donc l'annexion de la crimée et
la guerre en ukraine nous avions et
j'étais donc président de la république
exclut la russie du jeu malgré le g8 ce
qui avait été pour venir poser une vraie
sanction une vraie humiliation car il ne
raisonne qu'en termes d' humiliations ou
de domination il faut être dur ne jamais
penser qu'on va le séduit ne jamais
penser que la diplomatie avec des
arguments logiques avec des arguments
raison la diplomatie va l'emporter il ne
comprend que le rapport de force
il ya cent cinquante mille soldats
russes c'est ça ce sont les chiffres que
donne les américains en tout cas en face
ni terme encaisse qu'est ce qu'on a
après ça on n'a que l'armée ukrainienne
qui bien que s'étant considérablement
modernisé depuis dix ans et renforcer
notamment avec l'aide ou le soutien on
va dire de certains gouvernements
occidentaux en particulier celui des
etats-unis celui du royaume uni en
termes de matériel en termes de
formation
il n'y a néanmoins
c'est pas rien l'ukraine ses 44 millions
d'habitants c'est un territoire qui
avant tout ces annexions on va dire
était grand comme la france
et c'est un peuple pour autant qu'on
puisse le comprendre et le savoir est
très très mobilisé
donc s'il doit y avoir une guerre y aura
une résistance acharnée
mais jusqu'à preuve du contraire et
d'après les indices dont nous disposons
en ce moment les ukrainiens sont seuls
puisque quand bien même il ya une
solidarité d'un certain nombre de pays
notamment les pays de l'otan c'est une
solidarité qui ne va pas jusqu'à dire et
on pourrait se poser la question nous
ici autour de cette table sommes nous
prêts à envoyer les armées de l'otan un
peu la question soutenir
enfin affronter l'armée russe si celles
ci dépassent la ligne de francs actuels
l'occident l'a dit en plus une manière
particulière mais l'aviron pour
d'accueil marie mendras ce bon soir bien
politologue au cnrs aux séries
professeur à sciences po paris bienvenus
l'occident l'a déclaré le président by
dane a dit de toute façon il n'y aura
pas d'intervention militaire donc c'est
pas c'est pas effectivement l'argument
le plus fin pour faire peur à poutine
mais en fait si vous dites ça je suis
pas content après tout mais je vais pas
vous dire je vais pas vous tapez donc il
ne reste que les sanctions économiques
on va peut-être en dire un mot pour voir
la môle la faiblesse de l'arsenal de
sanctions économiques que l'on a disposé
contre contre le monsieur poutine
m'adresse comment vous analysez une
première question un peu générale la
situation
ce soir je te le disais en ouverture que
l'otan s'attend à une à une offensive
militaire massive sont les termes
employés par par l'otan oui la première
chose c'est que ce que les occidentaux
font depuis plusieurs semaines c'est qui
est très sage c'est de cesser de prendre
cottineau mot puisque il ne nous sert
quand même que des récits fabriquer et
il nous sert
très souvent des récits complètement
mensonger par exemple sur l'histoire de
l'ukraine et qu'il faut le prendre au
fait c'est à dire que analyser
très clairement
tout ce que fait l'armée russe tout ce
que font les autorités russes qu'on
vienne troubler déploie et d'en déduire
que tout est en place
pour une offensive s-class n'était pas
anticipée par le kremlin et c'est là ils
ont un véritable décalage par rapport à
notre rationalité
notre notre agilité et je dirais on est
quand même voilà une grande alliance
atlantique avec des pays très divers ray
et nous avons développé une des concepts
de sécurité est
extrêmement différents ceux de la russie
par exemple pour nous de plus en plus en
europe la sécurité des personnes est
plus importante que la sécurité
du d'une frontière à dos craquer ce qui
est vraiment intéressant c'est de voir
d'abord de rappeler à tous ceux qui nous
écoutent que poutine est très isolé
qu'il a perdu complètement le sens des
réalités que les hommes qui sont autour
de lui ont peur de lui parce qu'ils ne
savent pas ce qu'il va faire dans
l'heure qui suit donc cette confusion
cette imprévisibilité cette absence de
stratégie rationnelle elle est vécue de
manière encore beaucoup plus pénible en
russie même est évidemment en ukraine
les gens de joseph à une des premières
fois que j'entends cette analyse là vous
dites que c'est une sorte de fuite en
avant de la dit mi-août ici pour
consolider ou maintenir son pouvoir
c'est ça c'est pour priorité la russie
éternelle et c'est bien sûr mais ça fait
des années que j'écris et que je le dis
donc et
bien sûr c'est un peu fragile qui n'en a
l'air mais bien sûr sinon pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils iraient écouter bon soyons
clairs poutine en 2014 jean tandis que
vous en parliez tout à l'heure il a
quand même
oser essayer de mettre fin un changement
de régime pacifique en ukraine en
appelant à la violence
ensuite en annexant la crimée qui était
déjà de toute façon soucoupe militaires
russes depuis longtemps et en allant
plus loin ce qui n'avait pas été prévu
au départ un lait moi mes collègues
russes mes amis russes disait mon la
crimée c'est s était dans les tiroirs
depuis longtemps mais alors là allait
rentrer dedans
dans les provinces du donbass pourquoi
faire pour ensuite trouver des anciens
criminels russes qu'ont fait passer pour
une craignent un et qu'on appelle des
séparatistes faire d'efforts et faire un
donne ensuite
et faire des feux défaut ce république
autoproclamée populaire et cetera mais
ça c'est plutôt une marque de force
habitués de faiblesse il nous faut mais
qu'est ce qu'il a obtenu ses deux
ferries supplémentaires non mais ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est qu'une
fois qu'il a fait ça comme n'y avait pas
de stratégie derrière et que nous pays
occidentaux et avec les ukrainiens nous
avons réagi avec une extrême fermeté
les sanctions une diplomatie solidaire
poutine a été effectivement mis hors jeu
de certaines enceintes multilatérales
pendant pendant deux trois ans est-ce
qu'il a sauvé sa a été l'annexion de la
crimée qui lui a valu un certain soutien
populaire mais qui n'a pas duré très
longtemps ensuite il est est enferré
dans cette occupation du donne pas
forcément
ça vous fait réagir oui ça me fait
réagir au sens où moi je suis enfin je
respecte votre analyse mais l'impression
que l'on ait compris du reste quand on a
eu des contacts ici avec ses proches
quand j'étais à saint pétersbourg j'ai
rencontré de ses proches et quelques
mois au moment du forum économique tous
à dire le jeu j'ai pas l'impression que
je les sanctions ce régime de sanctions
et sept-îles cet isolement dans lequel
on tente de le confiner le touche
véritablement
l'ambassadeur russe à stockholm 10 j'en
ai rien à nous en avons rien à
des sanctions et quel est l'effet
quand vous regardez il acheter du blé
ils sont maintenant les premiers
exportateurs de blé pas de sanction vous
regardez sur les transats on les menace
de swift dessus de suspendre aurait
aussi ces deux transactions financières
ils vont immédiatement montés combrit en
s'appuyant sur la chine avec le ban il
ya déjà un système qui est en train de
se mettre en place ça va fonctionner les
transactions économiques en dollars
s'étaient 80% c'est 10 % maintenant on
en russie donc il a fait évoluer son
économie la fais moi c'est sur 240
tonnes ha et 2600 tonnes d'or dont kiel
après il dit que ce que vous lui fait à
chaque fois que l'on le on l'a privé en
matière agroalimentaire ce qui a
durement touché nos agriculteurs là nous
partons nous parlons d'une menace de
guerre quand même oui mais enfin non
mais oh là là de toute la période
d'essai en question parce que comme ça
semblait dire que les sanctions l'eau
isolé je pense qu'il est très content
isolé comme ça maintenant il va
simplement il va s'adresser à la chine
pas sûr que le couple fassent bon ménage
éternellement ça c'est un autre sujet
mais je pense que malheureusement on
utilise pour un style on va consacrer du
temps aux sanctions
décidé notamment par l'europe mais
sylvain kahn sur la fragilité moi je
reprends cet été intéressant de marie
mendras sur la fragilité de vladimir
poutine comment est ce que vous êtes sur
la même ligne comment vous le percevez
ça d'abord moi je suis si j'ose dire
marie mendras c'est une très grande
chercheuse sur la russie et moi j'essaye
modestement de comprendre comment
fonctionne l'union européenne donc je
suis de l'autre côté
moi ce qui me frappe beaucoup dans dix
ans dans cette crise c'est que je dirais
rapidement deux points le premier c'est
que l'otan
est toujours là et quand je dis le temps
est toujours là j'ai en mémoire et je
pense tout le monde ici on a tous en
mémoire les commentaires soient désabusé
soit très inquiets sont au contraire
très sarcastique qui ont quand même
vraiment fleuri à la suite de la
l'évacuation de l'afghanistan est de
kaboul sur le mode l'otan c'est fini
rebelote au moment de hocus donc quand
le gouvernement australien a décidé de
ne plus de dénoncer le contrat d'achat
de sous-marins à la france pour la chose
américain alors là on a rajouté une
couche sur la fin de l'otan alors que l
ac l'européanisme qui par l'otan c'est
depuis 1949 une alliance militaire pour
défendre le continent européen enfin le
continent pour défendre les pays libres
d'europe bon voilà et les américains ont
toujours considéré qu'il y avait
plusieurs théâtres d'opération donc en
tout cas peut-être que poutine a crû lui
aussi à cette analyse mais il se rend
compte que l'otan est extrêmement
cohérente
de ce point de vue là effectivement il
ya un objectif du président poutine qui
est pour autant qu'on le comprenne
vraiment de remettre complètement une
emprise russe sur tout l'espace
ex-soviétique ou post soviétique mais on
comprend avec la réaction de l'otan
quand tous les cas cette volonté va
s'arrêter aux frontières de l'otan hier
les trois anciennes républiques
socialistes soviétiques battre l'estonie
la lettonie de la lituanie il est clair
que il n'ya pas d'emprise possible de la
part du pouvoir russe on pourrait dire
la même chose pour la finlande qui a
longtemps appartenu à l'empiré russe au
19e siècle etc etc donc ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que nous on n'arrête pas de dire je dis
pas tout le monde mais ça fait partie
des clichés et des stéréotypes que les
européens sont désunis alors on la
réalité les européens parlent à
plusieurs voix ou deux plusieurs mois
mais quand il faut prendre les décisions
les sanctions effectivement monsieur le
sénateur a raison les sanctions ce ne
sont que les sanctions mais ce sont déjà
des sanctions bon donc c'est on va dire
c'est mieux que rien mais en tous les
cas s'il ya des gens des commentateurs
des intellectuels des hommes politiques
qui sont dans l'opposition
un peu partout en europe qui parle de
finlandisation de l'ukraine il n'y a pas
un ministre il n'y a pas un gouvernement
ou un chef d'état et de gouvernement qui
parle de finlande isation de l'ukraine
c'est à dire que alors même si ça ne
suffit pas à empêcher poutine d'agresser
militairement l'ukraine en tous les cas
il ya au moins une position forte
cohérente et uni des européens alors
est-ce qu'on veut aller plus loin il ya
ce qu'on voudrait que les européens avec
les américains dans le cas de l'otan
réagissent militairement c'est ça la
question qui nous est posée aujourd'hui
alors on va parler des justement
continuer de parler d'aidé des sanctions
et je vous propose l'une des dernières
réactions sur ce thème
celle du ministre français des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian les 27
sont tombés d'accord
grâce à des initiatives
nous sommes tombés d'accord sur
l'analyse de la situation va dire que
c'était pas trop compliqué mais sur la
gravité de la situation il les risques
que cela peut engendrer à la suite de la
violation du droit international
par la russie la suite aux six la
rupture des engagements pris par la
russie à la suite aussi de
l'action contre l'intégrité la
souveraineté de l'ukraine mais nous
sommes aussi tombés d'accord sur un
premier paquet de sanctions à
l'unanimité
donc je souhaitais un moment important
sylvie matelly je vous ai pas encore
donné la parole rappelle que vous êtes
économiste directrice adjointe de de
l'iris comment vous analysez ces
ces sanctions il ya la grande bretagne
qui est aussi de son côté annoncé des
des sanctions et peut-être aussi pour
rebondir sur ce que disait le sénateur
cambon tout à l'heure quel impact sur la
russie aujourd'hui est-ce que les
sanctions même plus importante même avec
cet aspect collectif là que les
européens veulent donner est ce que sql
elle frappe elles ont moins d'effet sur
la russie d'aujourd'hui que il ya huit
ans par exemple
oui tout à fait merci merci pour votre
invitation et bonjour à tous alors sûr
c'est sur ces sanctions de chaises une
première chose si les européens sont
unis pour prononcer des sanctions c'est
d'abord parce que le régime des
sanctions c'est un régime européen et
donc on ne sanctionne plus de manière
nationale
visuel on s'entend avec nos routes avec
nos partenaires et on sanctionne en
collectif donc ça c'est un premier
élément qui est très important et ces
sanctions sont gérés d'ailleurs à
bruxelles et même si elles ont des
dimensions nationales qu'elles sont
mises en place au niveau national le
deuxième élément qui est très important
à ne pas oublier dans la discussion
c'est le fait que si aujourd'hui on
prononce des sanctions à l'encontre de
la russie et ce à la lumière poutine l'a
très bien compris et on a beaucoup parlé
des faiblesses et les fragilités de la
russie et de vladimir poutine mais je
crois que il faut aussi souligner les
femmes les fragilités les faiblesses des
occidentaux dans ce dossier c'est que
personne personne personne ne veut
envoyer des européens ou des américains
et joe biden l'a bien rappelé la semaine
dernière sur le front pour se battre et
pour défendre le cren c'était déjà le
cas à l'époque de l époque de la crimée
et aujourd'hui on prononce des sanctions
patent finalement à l'homme pour un
espérant que la russie et de la ligne
poutine vont céder et vont reculer mais
plus de manière très symbolique pour
donner des signaux à d'autres pays qui
seraient tentés d'avoir le même type de
de politique impérialiste et de conquête
d'autres territoires ou en tout cas de
remise en cause de la souveraineté de
certains territoires donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
important et du bon sens dit très long
sur l'inefficacité des sanctions je
partage le point de vue du sénateur
cambon est d'autant plus inefficace dans
lequel la russie que vous l'avez rappelé
des sanctions ont été précédemment
imposées au moment de la crimée et que
ben là aussi l'économie russe est
également
le pouvoir en place sont adaptées en
fait à ces sanctions savent répondre à
ces sanctions et qu'aujourd'hui la
russie est autrement mieux préparée
qu'elle ne l'était il ya quelques années
aux sanctions qu'elle pourrait subir de
la part de l'union européenne ou des
états unis lemieux président le mieux
préparé il ya tout ce qui a été tout ce
qui a été déjà dit et puis également les
relations
économiques et politiques qui sont en
train de se de se louer de se renforcer
avec la chine encore une fois avec un
petit petite interrogation j'ai
surveillé toute la journée la question
chinoise et la réaction des chinois elle
se fait quand même relativement prudente
aujourd'hui les chinois ils ont bien
compris leur intérêt et enfin dernier
élément qui qui dit montre notre
faiblesse y compris dans le dans le
nôtre politique de sanctions c'est que
et on s'en est rendu compte avec la
crimée vous en avait déjà parlé dans
cette émission c'est que les sanctions
il faut il y aller à la question de leur
efficacité on vient de revient de la
tranchée il évoqué mais il ya aussi la
question des de lembach kenzo sur
vous-même en fait le sanctioner est
souvent en retour de bâton sanctionné
lui même et on sent bien dans les
sanctions qui ont été annoncées par les
européens qui a quand même une très très
très grande prudence en la matière on
nous parle de banque on nous parle de
l'accès aux marchés financiers européens
pour financer la dette souveraine russe
mais pour l'instant on reste extrêmement
flou parce que je pense qu'il ya des
études d'impact qui vont être faites de
manière beaucoup plus poussé que cela
n'avait été le cas pour la crimée dans
le cas de la primaire parce que on a
lourdement payé nous européens les
sanctions qu'on a pu imposer à la russie
au moment des événements mais on y
reviendra jeu je vous proposerai la
question sur l'impact pour les
entreprises françaises où les groupes
français qui sont présents en russie
aujourd'hui on y revient à tout à
l'heure mais marie morale je voudrais
avoir votre expertise effectivement sur
ce que ces sanctions pourraient
provoquer en russie et notamment dans ce
contexte de fragilité que vous parce
qu'il faut remettant dans un contexte
les propos qui viennent d'être tenus
pouvaient peut-être encore être tenus en
2014 2015
mais les sanctions ont énormément changé
et évolué ces dernières années et elles
ne sont d'ailleurs pas que prises par
l'union européenne et par tous les
gouvernements démocratiques japon
australie canada etats unis zh et que
les sanctions dont nous parlons depuis
trois quatre ans et est aujourd'hui ce
sont des sanctions ciblées contre les
élites dirigeantes russe et quand contre
tous leurs moyens financiers donc c'est
une stratégie qui à mon avis fonctionne
très bien et si vous avez regardé
l'incroyable théâtre
hier soir au kremlin
avec les hommes et la femme
qui sont censés diriger des principaux
organes et institutions de la fédération
de russie et qui tremblait devant devant
poutine parce que comme ils ne savent
pas ce que poutine va décider une heure
plus tard ou ne pas décider etc et
ont ces hommes là que nous avons vus à
la télévision qui font donc partie de ce
fameux conseil de sécurité de la russie
ils sont tous sous sanction depuis des
années ce qu'il veut dire que il un
certain nombre de leurs avoirs sont
gelés si leur famille est installée à
l'étranger ils ne peuvent plus y aller
parce qu'il peut finir en plus de visas
et leurs enfants ne peuvent plus étudiée
dans nos université et c'est ça qui est
important tous les empêche fab la
guillotine d'avancé militairement ses
pions aux gens ce que monsieur poutine a
avancé militairement ses pions
aujourd'hui
excusez moi mais je comprends bien que
je vais à contre courant parce que vous
avez donc j'essaye justement d'expliquer
j'ai commencé en vous disant nous ne
prenons plus monsieur poutine au mot
nous le prenons au fait donc il
aujourd'hui il a en effet par la
reconnaissance
de l'ensemble des provinces de donetsk
est lougansk est pas seulement le tiers
de ces territoires qui est occupé par
des séparatistes entre guillemets
soutenu par l'armée russe depuis 2014
c'est en deux fait une déclaration de
guerre puisque il jette aux orties les
accords de minsk alors que s'il avait
dit nous ne reconnaissons que les
républiques autoproclamées sera donc il
fait une déclaration de guerre qui lui
vaut des sanctions ou là je suis en
total désaccord avec ce qui a été dit
qui justement mais poutine en grande
difficulté de plus en plus isolé au sein
des élites c'est à dire qu'il fait peur
à à ses propres
élites et surtout il a envoyé cette fois
ci des troupes avec des insignes crc
plus les petits hommes verts 2014 et qui
donc sont dans cette partie d'une base
occupée
est-ce que ils vont lancer une offensive
majeure pour rentrer en territoire
ukrainien sur 100 km 200 km nous n'en
savons rien parce que le problème de
vladimir poutine et que c'est un homme
dont qui qui qui qui se sent assiégée
qui ne veut pas tomber et il prend un
risque majeur en faisant ça c'est le
risque de perdre cette guerre il faut
bien le comprendre ce n'est pas parce
que les pays de l'otan ne vont pas
envoyer des hommes sandy ground comme on
dit en américains que nous ne sommes pas
un vrai soutien sécuritaire
à l'ukraine allaient beau fils aux
russes à la georgie et était donc il
faut avoir une vision un petit peu
j'appellerai presque obsolète de la
guerre alors je vais vous donner la
parole sénateur comeau mais je vous
propose d'entendre une autre réaction
celle du ministre ukrainien des affaires
étrangères c'était il ya il ya moins
d'une heure
me trop cool et bah c'est pour vous dire
ce que vous venez de dire il lance un
appel à l'union européenne écoutez il ya
encore des cov
j'ai appelé lieu à mettre de côté toutes
les hésitations toutes les réticences et
le scepticisme qui existe dans la
capitale européenne
et a donné à l'ukraine la promesse d'une
future adhésion à l'union européenne
un
la meilleure décision stratégique que
l'europe puisse prendre à l'heure
actuelle et de prendre littéralement
l'ukraine à son compte ce jour
c'est intéressant christian caumont
parce que c'est vraiment on est dans des
enjeux de long terme quoi ces encres et
l'ukraine dans l'europe et la dea et la
désencrée si j'ose dire le terme n'est
pas très bien choisis de de son passé
soviétique et russe
sur ce sujet et pour être le plus
objectif possible il faut effectivement
revenir un tout petit peu en arrière
pour voir que dans les accords de minsk
il y avait aussi des obligations
qui pesait sur l'ukraine qui n'ont pas
pu être respectées notamment cette
fameuse loi de régionalisation qui
devait donner l'autonomie à ces
républiques séparatistes
parce que et la raison c'est pas la
volonté politique de ce pauvre président
c'est ainsi que nous avons reçu ici qui
nous l'a expliqué en long et en large
c'est que la rada le parlement ukrainien
et c'est la foire d'emploi il faut juste
assister à des séances n'a pas été mon
âne on en a vu des séquences c'est
quelque chose d'inouï et la première
difficulté du président c'est un ski ces
mesures et l'état ukrainien dans dans
ses responsabilités dans ces dans ses
compétences je pense que c'est un c'est
un vrai sujet
parce qu' un certain nombre de voix
s'élèvent maintenant pour dire le cren
aurait pu faire un effort on vous avait
demandé de respecter ses engagements et
c'est une île ont respecté leurs
engagements mais pas les russes savez
j'ai suivi de très près les accords de
mines ce processus j'ai parlé avec
plusieurs des protagonistes qui était à
minsk et la régionalisation et
l'arrivée les accords 2000 ce que j'ai
lu dans toutes les langues que je
connais par coeur disent que aussi que
pour avoir des élections dans ces
territoires occupés il faut qui est un
retrait des troupes et bien sûr les
russes ont essayé d'imposer une lecture
de mines ce qui était non il faut
d'abord
retiré ces deux républiques à l'ukraine
et après on retirera nos troupes et
voilà donc je pense que vraiment
médecins sur le dos des députés
ukrainiens je vais assez régulièrement à
la rada ukrainienne ne tombant pas dans
la propagande dans la propagande russe
l'anglais mais mais ils on perd tout
n'est pas fait cousy d'être objectif uni
les économistes n'ont pas pu être
appliqué face et de notoriété à cause
des russes à materis je posais une
question sur l'europe parce que c'est
intéressant ce que ce qu'on en termine à
l'instant ce ministre ukrainien des
affaires étrangères et sur la stratégie
de poutine est ce que finalement elle
est pas contre-productif c'est à dire
que il soude encore plus les ukrainiens
il les soude encore plus à l'europe
il faut avoir mémoire que en 2014 si on
considère que 2014 et le le début de la
crise actuelle disons voilà même si
effectivement évidemment on pourrait
considérer que tout commence avec la
chute de l'union soviétique m'enfin bon
en tous les cas en 2014 faut quand même
se rappeler que on est on est les
ukrainiens sont sur le point de signer
un accord d'association avec l'union
européenne que le président de l'époque
finalement change d'avis parce que
kremlin fait pression sur lui et que les
européens disent bon on pourrait revenir
là dessus bon ben il faut choisir vous
pouvez pas être à la fois dans un accord
d'association avec l'ue eux et en même
temps dans l'union eurasiatique que le
président poutine vous demande de
ratifier ou de rejoindre donc il ya une
révolution populaire démocratique dit de
maidan changement de régime et mai et
puis finalement on passe sur les détails
cet accord d'association entre l'ue et
l'ukraine il a fini par être signé un
voilà bon donc comme avec la moldavie la
géorgie voilà donc l'union européenne
quoi qu'on en dise un
lll garde son cap l'union européenne n'a
pas d'armé l'union européenne a pour
seule
organisation de défense
et organisation militaire l'otan c'est
un choix collectif qui est fait depuis
1949 qui non seulement n'a jamais été
remis en cause par personne un peu
parler français mais c'est bien les sols
et qui a été renforcé par l'adhésion de
la pologne
et en particulier et des états baltes
bon donc l'union européenne n'a jamais
prétendu
devenir une alliance militaire à elle
seule par contre sur l'intégration qu'on
peut appeler économico sociopolitique
elle garde son cap l'accord
d'association a fini par être signée il
ya des sanctions même si ça ne
fonctionne plus ou moins bien bon là il
ya un débat entre spécialistes je me
permettrai pas d'ajouter quelque chose
et donc très logiquement le gouvernement
ukrainien qui sait être soutenu à ce
sujet par entre 60 et 75 % de son
opinion publique dit voilà on a bien
compris qu'on allait pas rentrer dans
l'otan bon mais au moins qu'on rentre
dans lieux et sa poutine s'est
probablement je parle ce contrôle le
mari m'embrasse c'est probablement ce
qu'il craint le plus c'est à dire à
force de dire ben les ukrainiens et les
russes c'est le même peuple donc ya pas
de raison qu'il y ait deux pays et puis
si finalement il ya ce soi disant pays
qui n'en est pas un qui devient une
démocratie et qui rentre dans l'union
européenne
avec tout ce que ça veut dire c'est à
dire l'état de droit
[Musique]
les libertés individuelles qui sont
placés au coeur de la société
alors à ce moment là si c'est les mêmes
pourquoi ça serait pas aussi le cas en
russie il n'y a pas de raison si vous
excuser si l'uci l'ukraine peut rentrer
dans l'ue devenir une démocratie un état
de droit ça veut dire que la russie peut
le faire aussi si on suit poutine donc
il faut surtout empêcher à moi c'est ce
que je comprends la stratégie de poutine
pour ton complice d'en comprendre
quelque chose ouais ce que je comprends
c'est en tous les cas il veut surtout
éviter que y ait ce genre de
déclarations de la part du ministre d'un
gouvernement légitime la démocratie est
la démocratisation pas c'est clair on
peut dire ça comme ça je je sais bien
que l'ukraine s'est pas encore un modèle
de démocratie qui a encore beaucoup de
corruption enfin bon après tout nous
dont l'ua ça va ça va beaucoup mieux
comment ici on allait en gris dorman bon
on a les polonais du crij qui écorne
l'état de droit enfin bon voilà enfin de
façon si l'union européenne est une
démocratie pure et parfaite ça se
saurait mais on n'est pas un peuple de
roi comme des héros sont donc pas les
yeux de dieu c'est déjà formidable tout
ce qu'on fait une dernière question
pardon
franck au centre et sylvie matelly sur
les grands groupes français qui qui sont
présents russie est ce qu'ils peuvent
souffrir d'éventuelles contre sanctions
et comment il faut se l'imaginer la
suite
ils peuvent déjà souffrir des sanctions
ça c'est certain parce que les sanctions
leur empêche un certain nombre
d'activités et de collaboration avec des
acteurs économiques en russie donc ça
c'est un fait simplement ils ont déjà
vécu les sanctions de 2014 et bien
évidemment il ya déjà des actes idée des
coopérations des contrats qui ont été
largement pénalisées ils ont déjà
l'habitude de ça avec des entreprises
qui ont renoncé à un certain nombre de
contrats qu'elle avait en russie et des
acteurs économiques on parlait tout à
l'heure des agriculteurs qui ont
profondément qui ont vu baisser très
nettement leurs exportations à
destination de la russie donc ça c'est
un élément qui est clair et c'est ce que
j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure c'est que
je n'étais pas là pour me positionner
sur faut que les sanctionner ou pas
sanctionné c'est à mon sujet moi ce sur
quoi je trouve assez la performance des
sanctions donc ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de savoir est ce qu'elles vont avoir un
impact pas et ce que je disais c'est
qu'elles ont un impact relativement
limité
par rapport à l'objectif qui est fixé
faire reculer vladimir poutine et la
russie on l'a vu en crimée saleh ba
reculait et le deuxième élément c'est
l'attention qui doit être portée et qui
portait très nettement j'interprète le
sou des sanctions qui ont été annoncées
comme un travail qu'il fait derrière
pour mesurer l'impact des sanctions sur
notre économie c'est l'impact de ce que
les sanctions vont avoir en retour sur
nos économies et nos acteurs économiques
vous avez un certain nombre
d'entreprises dans le secteur de
l'énergie dans le secteur de
l'aéronautique et du spatial je parlais
tout à l'heure des agriculteurs se sont
très clairement aujourd'hui les secteurs
qui ont déjà été pénalisé par les
sanctions précédentes et qui risquent
d'être pénalisés par une sanction à
venir alors avec peut-être une nouveauté
le fait qu' on cible très clairement le
secteur financier alors pour une simple
et bonne raison c'est que sur les
secteurs d'économie réelle on s'aperçoit
qu'on paye un prix fort sur les
sanctions ciblées qui existe trente ans
et qui sont prononcés depuis plusieurs
années à l'encontre de la russie c'est
pas du tout nouveau ce qu'on est en
train de mettre en place sur les
sanctions ciblées elles ont eu assez peu
d'effets en réalité elles ont gêné oui
quelques dignitaires russes mais elles
ont eu assez peu de l'effet et l on
tente aujourd'hui la la sanction
financière pardon de vous interrompre
merci beaucoup sylvie matelly merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
silvacane rappel le titre de ce livre
histoire de la construction de l'europe
depuis 18 45 aux presses universitaires
de france merci mathieu à demain on se
retrouve demain pour un nouveau numéro
de sens public et puis ne ratez pas
sur notre antenne oriane nancy ni dans
bonjour chez vous au soir patrick kanner
demain le sénateur ps du nord président
yves au ps ici et là